plus d'un an après la mort de
Charles-Henri Saulnier à Saint genou sa
compagne vient d'être mise en examen et
placé sous contrôle judiciaire pour
meurtre et violence sur conjoint en
récidive entre le 1er juillet et le 9
août 2022 elle est soupçonnée d'avoir
tué son compagnon et maquiller sa mort
en suicide par pendaison la famille de
Charles-Henri Saulnier avait porté
plainte pour homicide ne croyant pas en
cette thèse du suicide explication de
Clémence dusk
c'est à Saint genou comme une située à
une dizaine de minutes de Tours que le
corps de Charles-Henry a été découvert
dans son jardin en août 2022 les secours
constatent sont décès et conjoint assure
l'avoir découvert pendu à un arbre puis
l'avoir détaché mais la famille du
défunt ne croit pas un suicide une
plainte est déposée selon nos confrères
du Parisien deux autopsies plus tard la
thèse du décès par pendaison est remise
en cause le couple gemilien est déjà
connu de la justice notamment la
compagne colline après un passage de
Charles Henry aux urgences en 2021 pour
un décollement de la rétine des marques
de violences sont constatées sur lui
l'affaire passe en correctionnelle et la
jeune femme est condamnée à six mois de
prison avec sursis pour violence
habituelle sur son conjoint en juin 2023
cette dernière âgée de 33 ans a été mise
en examen pour récidive de violence
ainsi que pour meurtre aurait-elle
maquillée la mort de son conjoint par un
suicide en tout cas son avocat Maître
Audebert détaille que sa cliente a été
laissée libre et sous contrôle
judiciaire il regrette la révélation de
certains éléments du dossier à la presse
et invite je cite à laisser du temps
autant de son côté la procureur de la
République de Tours a confirmé cette
mise en examen et rappelle que la jeune
femme bénéficie de la présomption
d'innocence une affaire dense et
complexe qui est toujours en cours
d'instruction